this is a video I'm making for Avante
the young man who was working two jobs
with a one-year-old who's struggling and
said he was sick and tired of being poor
and didn't know how to get out I didn't
have time to answer you when I was
walking but I wanted to take this minute
to give you a longer answer I'll read
you the Tweet maybe we'll put it up on
the screen to ivonte the young man who
stopped me at the grocery store working
two jobs with one-year-old who asked
advice on how to get ahead I gave you a
short answer because I was in a rush and
it ate at me so if you follow me here
maybe you'll read this what you're going
through is tough being so young and
already having to support a child is not
easy but you'll have the opportunity to
become an amazing inspiration in a way I
never could your success story will
become your sermon that being said under
the advice you're going to need to
assume that luck isn't real or that it
applies to everyone else but you because
the only way you're going to get out of
your surroundings is by having something
of value that other people want and
right now the only thing you have is
your time with low skills to trade which
is a hard game to play you have to trade
a lot of it only to get a little so your
main objective is to have the time to
learn a skill while providing for your
family that means in the short term your
family may have to suffer scratch that
your family will suffer but better now
when they're 2 young to remember than
when they're too old to forget again not
forever but for now so these are the
things you're going to have to do and
this isn't dabble stuff this is wake the
[__] up because if you don't you're
gonna blink and be 30 and in the same
spot but worse number one cut all costs
and I mean all costs you don't need out
anymore for anything and if you're
hungry you deal with it if it's not from
a discount grocery store you don't buy
it clothing ha what you've got is
everything you need for the next two
years period no exceptions reuse trade
or go to Goodwill you go to work you go
home and home is ideally with your
family and when I say family your folks
and if you don't have folks who have got
who've got room or a couch or a basement
that you can say at the worst case is
with another family also trying to make
it and save so it's six of you eight of
you 10 of you in one spot all splitting
it all of you contributing and it's
gonna be as cheap as you possibly can
number two increase your income you're
working two jobs your free time I want
you to spend applying to other jobs
closer to what you want to do he said he
didn't like either of the things that he
was doing at that time so any at home
phone sales job has starter roles that
require zero experience to pay 40 000 a
year or more or do that and work your
other job in between if you can't drive
Uber if you don't have a car save up
until you do number three the easiest
thing to sell is someone else's stuff so
start there then learn how to buy stuff
for cheap and then flip it the bigger
the thing the more you make you go from
flipping cards to Furniture to home and
the limit never really stops from there
on Final note I could hear the stress in
your voice when you were talking to me
about your situation it sounded like you
didn't know what to do sadness comes
from a lack of options it's a feeling of
hopelessness but whenever you feel that
I want you to think this is ignorance
not sadness it means I don't know enough
and that I can control you asked me to
come work for free but I have no need
for low-skilled labor but I do have a
need for high skilled beasts it's why I
make the books and the courses and the
content everywhere for free so use those
then get yourself a high paying job and
every day apply for higher paying ones I
recommend sales to start then once you
get in there for the love of God work
until your fingers bleed because you
have no other option you have no luck
nothing is going to work out for you
you're not going to catch a break you're
going to have to make it happen you're
going to have to force it you've got to
become undeniable and the best news is
is that you can do that in less than a
year so that's my advice number one cut
all your costs everything number two
work more to make more and apply to
better jobs and then learn to sell three
start selling more expensive stuff and
then eventually sell your own the game
is Just trading up over and over and
over again you're just a few trades away
from a very different financial
situation so Avante I wanted to add on
top of that you're in a tough spot and I
think some of the words I probably just
said to you might hopefully hit home
somewhere but one of the hard things
that you've got going on right now is
like when I saw you you were wearing
relatively nice clothes and I wasn't
gonna like bash you on it when I saw you
but I want to take the opportunity to
say like you know better you know what I
mean like you know that like if you're
struggling with money that's the last
thing that you should spend money on
right and um I think one of the
difficulties especially when you're
younger is you've got your friends you
got your family and especially if
they're all poor then they have terrible
views around money they might not
approve of all the stuff you're learning
on the internet and trying to try these
new things out and the real real is like
you're gonna fail a lot and and they're
going to see say she told you so and the
tough part is is they're going to be
right most of the time except it's one
of those things where it's 99 right but
100 wrong is that anybody who bets
against you for this thing being the
thing is usually going to be right it's
just like a parent who says you're gonna
break up with this person you're gonna
break up with this person but they're
right with every single person you ever
date except for the person you marry and
then they're 100 wrong and if you have
the perspective of listing to that it
can be incredibly disheartening and so
number one is I want you to go on a on a
different information diet so you need
to be able to ignore all the stuff that
they're giving you because like the best
way to stay poor is to listen to poor
people about how to get rich you're
already taking great steps by like
washing content and doing stuff just
keep doing more of that and I'm sure
you're growing you know you have your
baby with that's your world like anybody
who does it who's not trying to build
Avante 2.0 with you doesn't deserve your
time because like right now you have a
wallet of money and you got a wallet of
minutes and like every single person
you're choosing to pay minutes to or pay
dollars to has to earn their keep and
earning their keep in this season of
your life is them helping you get to
where you want to go now I don't know
what you're making in your job I'm just
going to assume the extreme scenario if
you're making a minimum wage at both
jobs and you're working 80 hours doing
that I get it and I respect the hustle
which is why I'm making this video you
need to get more for your time and right
now the extra time on top of that 80 is
you sleeping and probably spending time
with your kid and what I'm going to say
people in your surroundings will say
like that guy's extreme or that guy he's
he's not balanced and the answer is yes
I am extreme and I am unbalanced for the
season that you're in I think you should
be too because the thing is it's like if
you don't take action on this five years
is going to go by and nothing's going to
change because you're not going to get
ahead like you need to get your head
firmly above water because you probably
barely feel like you can keep your head
above surface right that's where all
that stress is coming from and you don't
know what to do so to get the water
lower you've got to lower your time
budget and your money budget and I want
to go really extreme with you and I'm
not telling you to do anything I didn't
do all right I owned my car in cash
which I think was a five or six thousand
dollar car and I slept in a room with
another dude in a house that had six
other people in it and we all split it
so I wasn't in a terrible neighborhood I
just paid 400 a month in a nice
neighborhood because I didn't have my
own place and so I had to split my
kitchen and I had to deal with the fact
that three of them had dogs and would
[__] and piss everywhere all the time it
sucked but you know it would have sucked
more not being able to have the money to
buy the courses and the seminars and the
workshops that I was able to attend with
the extra that I saved so I could learn
my next skills and so right now food and
shelter is the only thing you spend
money on and you're gonna drop
everything else and you're gonna drop
those expenses to the greatest degree
possible and either your girl is working
if she's working then you can have child
care if she's not working to take care
of the kid then you need to say listen
sweetie like I got to do this for us
right now and so like you're putting
your sacrifice in which is you're
sacrifice in your career so we can you
can be with the kid I need to sacrifice
the kid right now so I can have the
career so that together as a family
we're balanced rather than the
individual so there's two levels of
balance I want you to think about one is
the macro which is like you can be
bounced over your lifespan when you're
retired you'll have more time you can go
to Europe you can do whatever the other
stuff is right and also you can be
balanced in a family unit your wife
might spend more time with the kid than
she does in her career but you're gonna
spend more time anything to do with the
kit for now cut out the people who are
taking your time easy way to see this is
like if the people in your life don't
have bigger dreams for you than you do
ignore all of their advice let's just
ignore them entirely and I know that
that's simple to say and hard to do but
you're in a hard situation and I think
the question is whether you can be
harder than your circumstances right
there and you have to be to get out of
this luck has already dealt you a [__]
hand let's assume he's never going to
give you the right hand you're never
going to get lucky but you still need to
win and so now it's like how do I do
that if you have a car you can have more
flexible hours if you drive through
there that's something that I recommend
for a lot of people if you don't have a
car you need to save up as fast as you
can to get one buy one in cash negotiate
try and get yourself five to ten
thousand dollar car in cash you don't
have payments you just have the
insurance which because it's a cheap car
will be less the remainder of your time
and you got to tell your lady this it's
like I'm gonna be spending four hours a
day every day watching these videos and
this isn't me Doom scrolling on YouTube
I need you to pick one skill that you
want to have and only consume stuff
about that this is my one thing I'll let
you buy it's a timer you can buy for
five bucks not your phone and you set
the timer set it for those four hours a
day and every time you look away you
stop the timer you do four hours of real
work of studying the skill after you've
done enough of that work and you're like
what's enough 20 hours like you're like
oh I could do that soon yeah I know so
I'm telling you you can get out of this
fast you can switch those four hours of
you learning the basics of that skill
just spending the rest of your time
being the most amazing applicant to new
jobs that exists in the world I didn't
say go apply to jobs I said be the best
candidate that has ever applied and
you're like I don't have experience and
you can address that like what I don't
have an experience I will make up for
and hustle and you prove that by
messaging multiple people at every
company with a snippet personalized to
each of them you know what other people
do like they take a half step they copy
and paste the same thing to all four
people and you know what the poor people
do yeah yeah he copy and pasted the same
message to me don't do that be personal
look at the HR recruiter look at the
head of talent look at director of
whatever and message each of them on
LinkedIn if you don't have a LinkedIn go
get one it's free and when you submit
your resume put a personalized cover
letter on it after reading from the
website what that business is about when
you read the job description good job
description say what they want the
person to do and say like I will be able
to help do this thing because of these
things right and especially a lower
level role your resume is not going to
matter as much don't let anybody around
you say that or fool you into that what
will matter especially for low-level
roles is hustle so every employer wants
to see if somebody's going to go out of
their way to go above and beyond and so
you demonstrate that you're gonna go
above and beyond and guess what's gonna
happen you're going to do this for five
different places you're gonna write a
custom thing it's gonna take you four
hours to do the research write the
custom thing message 20 people because
it's going to be four people at all five
places you know what's gonna happen
nothing because you're not lucky so what
are you gonna have to do gotta be
undeniable do you think if you applied
to a thousand places like that over the
next six months you wouldn't get a job I
think you would you think if like after
you got off your shift and you drove
over and you said hey I just want to let
you know not in a creepy way and say hey
just let you know I applied to put my
resume I messaged a couple you guys I
just want to let you know I'm really
excited about the opportunity don't want
to be overbearing but if you guys would
give me a shot I promise I'll wear part
of any other candidate here and I'd like
to show you that I'm demonstrating that
by these things you're like I have proof
that I'm saying I'm not just making this
up proof that I will work harder and you
know what will happen one of them say
I'll give you a shot and then when they
give you that shot shove it in
everyone's face how hard you work not by
what you say but by what you do be
silent and just kill look at what the
top guy does and do twice as much as
that guy does be Kobe for whatever the
job is if you don't know the whole story
about Kobe he did three practices a day
while everyone else did one or two
because he wanted to get ahead and in
the beginning he was worse than them and
then he got as good as them and then he
became better than them and he kept
doing three practices a day until
eventually no one could catch up because
if they were doing three practices a day
they would just keep up with his rate of
progress but he got ahead and so the guy
who's number one at whatever that
business is probably works better than
you and he works longer than you and so
you can't just match him to get ahead
because he'll always be ahead you gotta
match his current effort and then do
your I'm gonna get ahead of you effort
like when he clocks out is when your
work clocks in that's when Avante 2.0
clocks in and the thing is it's like if
you can adopt this like if you can
really internalize this you're gonna
Crush you're going to win you can make
luck not a factor when I had Jacob my 19
year old my son son I'm kidding when I
was talking to him I think he was 16
actually 6 15 or 16 when I started
talking about this imagine he's even
less reason to get a job than you all
right less experience I gave him three
words and he said he still remembers him
this day I said volume negates luck if
you need to put it put on the back of
your phones as a reminder to yourself
because in the beginning the volume
you're gonna do is the timer of you
watching the videos and taking the notes
and watching the videos learning the
lingo learning the language so that when
you get into an interview you know what
to say and then reps is going to be
watching mock interviews on YouTube
watching people who are hiring experts
talk about the best ways to present
watch some of Layla's videos about how
to interview correctly you do that stuff
you'll put yourself ahead of other
people volume okay cool now you're like
okay but I'm not getting interviews
volume negates up crank the timer start
doing the Reps one a day two a day three
a day four day five a day six a day 10 a
day every single day you're like wait
that's 40 messages that are personalized
and 10 cover letters yeah that'll
probably take about four hours and then
what do you do tomorrow set the timer
you do it again next day set the timer
you do it again what do you do the next
day set the timer you do it a [__]
game and you keep doing yeah and on the
ones that you really really like you
drive over there after you get off your
shift you stop by and you say hey I'm
Avante I'm really excited about the
opportunity I think I could help I
applied you got a couple message from me
I promise I'm not a weirdo I just did it
because I wanted to stick out for the
rest of the pile because I know you guys
I'm sure for an opportunity as good as
this you probably got a lot of people
who are interested I just promise you
that I just want a shot you say that
they will give you the interview and if
they don't
someone will and once you do get that
job and you work harder than everyone
else
you turn the dial and you don't do it
for a week you don't work harder than
everyone else for a week you don't work
hard at them for a month you don't work
harder than for six months you work
harder than the top guy for a year for
two years you're like well [__] dude I'm
already like two or three years from now
yeah I said it was a season but on the
other side of this season is everything
else that you want and so if I said
Devonte in 36 months are you willing to
give me 36 months to get yourself out of
the feeling that you have right now
you're like I'm sick and tired of being
poor I'm sick of not being able to buy
the stuff for my girl that I want I'm
sick and I'll be able to provide for my
kid I want him to be in a good zip code
I want to be able to have good school I
want them to be able to have these
things there's a price tag on them the
question is just whether or not you're
willing to pay it if you're willing to
pay it
crank the dial and volume will negate
locked but you can't rely on lock you
can rely on volume because that I
promise you independent of race color
socioeconomic background really wait
some racist socioeconomic backgrounds
are how someone appears uh gives them an
advantage short but if you do it a
million times just give an advantage
because you only need one yes if there's
like a lesson I can like have you like
etch into your brain is that there's a
significant amount of money and
opportunity that sits on the other side
of being willing to be rejected by a
stranger if you get rejected a thousand
times you are no worse off than you are
right now in fact you're better why
because you have a thousand times
experience and so you either learn or
you win which means in both cases by
doing you win by default I'll give you a
little analogy so let's say you and your
buddy are thinking about asking a girl
to prom it'll make sense in a second and
your buddy's like ah man I want to ask
Nicole and you're like all right man why
don't you go ask her it's like what if
she says no he's like well then you're
in the exact same position you are now
which is you have no prom date you will
also have no prom date but you'll have
experience of asking one wrong what
happens when you talk to the next Road
you'll probably be a little less nervous
and you probably realize that you'll
survive you you will live if you hear a
no and if you ask 100 girls do you think
one of them will say yes to your prom
date probably and in that situation what
are you now better off than you were
before you asked the moral of the story
there is that you lose nothing from no
you only stand something to gain from
yeses and one yes can change your entire
life and so if you're willing to be
rejected and see the rejections as you
learning meaning you win and see the
yeses as you also winning then you can't
move and everybody else around you who's
poor is going to convince you otherwise
they're going to be like why are you
still doing this man stop bothering
those people man you're never going to
get the job and you need to readjust
your expectations set your goals slower
hey that stuff's not for us right
they're going to tell you those things
because the thing is is that you have
something that I do not have and that
many people won't have is that you have
a hard [__] beginning you have a
harder and bigger monster to slay but
the bigger the monster the more epic the
hero and so these are the stories that
you're going to someday tell and these
are gonna be the sermons that you're
going to be able to give to other
Avantes in the future if you can't even
muster the willingness to fail for
yourself be willing to fail for your kid
for the story that you're to tell them
and be willing to fail for the hundred
other a thousand other Avantes that
you'll be able to someday tell your
story to so they can get out of their
situation so I didn't have time to say
that but hopefully I'll give you a
couple more minutes to give you a little
more context I think I can speak
confidently for all imagination we're
all rude for you